hey guys it is Thursday the eighth of
October today my name is Justin you're
watching games funny first up today
video game voice actors may indeed be
going on strike the Screen Actors Guild
American Federation of television and
radio artists announced that 96.5 two
percent of its members voted in favor of
the strike meaning the board has the
authority to declare a strike if
necessary the Union after a number of
changes including the introduction of
royalties the actors who performed voice
work on particularly successful games
which sell at least two million copies
in addition to that they're calling for
shorter recording session to attend to
vocal stress and to have stunt
coordinators onset to assist performance
capture actors the union has said they
aren't looking to satisfy any crazy
demands and several prominent voice
actors have spoken out in favor of the
move including jennifer hale and from
wheaton next sabbath Erza has confirmed
the minimum and recommended pc specs for
Fallout 4 minimum specs call for an
Intel Core i5 2300 or equivalent 8
gigabytes of ram and an nvidia gtx 550
TI or AMD radeon HD 7870 15 gigabytes of
memory comparatively the recommended
specs require you to have an intel core
i7 47 90 or equivalent 80 gigabytes of
ram and an nvidia gtx 780 with 3
gigabytes of memory or an equivalent
card you'll need the 30 gigabytes of
hard drive space on your PC or 28 to 35
gigabytes of space free on your ps4 or
Xbox one depending on your region
Bethesda also confirmed that fallout
will unlock at 1201 local time in all
territories and the pip-boy edition will
come with a super cool looking Park
poster sony has announced that come
october nine ps4 consoles will drop in
price in the US
Canada the ps4 will now run you 350
bucks in the US and 450 in Canada the
prize cat has also been reflected in a
number of upcoming bundles including the
black ops 3 1 terabyte star wars
battlefront and NHL 16 packages you can
check out the full list of altered
prices in our story on gamespot sony
explained the move by saying our goal
that's PlayStation has always been to
provide the best gameplay experiences at
the best value we feel this new
compelling price will open the doors to
even more gamers that have yet to
purchase the system let me know down in
that comment section if your pc can run
fallout 4 or if you'll be picking up a
ps4 to play it you can add the games but
we've got stories on destiny sales and a
massive witcher 3 patch that is
everything i have you today but do
remember that you can pop by same time
tomorrow for my top 5 stories of the
whole gaming week I will catch you then